JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
KENNEDY!
"THE FIVE" ."
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, CNN
PRODUCERS WERE DREAMING OF THEIR
NEXT STORMY HEADLINE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WELCOMED HOME
THREE AMERICANS IMPRISONED IN
NORTH KOREA.
AND HE DID IT TO GREAT RATINGS.
>> I THINK THAT YOU PROBABLY
BROKE THE ALL-TIME HISTORY
TELEVISION RATING FOR 3:00 IN
THE MORNING.
THIS IS A SPECIAL NIGHT FOR
THESE THREE REALLY GREAT PEOPLE
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I WANT TO THANK KIM JONG UN WHO
REALLY WAS EXCELLENT TO THREE
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
>> Greg: I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD HEAR THAT.
BUT I NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD
HAVE A FORMER REALITY GAME SHOW
HOST RUNNING THE MOST POWERFUL
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD EVER.
AND THAT REALITY AND THE REALITY
OF THIS MORNING'S RELEASE ARE
CONNECTED.
THE RELEASE, WHAT DOES IT MEAN,
AND TO THE NORTH KOREA THREAT,
HAPPIER DAYS TO ALL OF US, IT IS
TOO SOON TO TELL, BUT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO BE IN YOUR OWN PRISM OF
BIAS NOT TO SEE THIS AS A
PROMISING STEP TO THE CORRECTION
OF THE WORLD, RIGHT, CHUCK?
>> IT IS SO TROUBLING TO SAY
THAT KIM JONG UN TREATED THE
AMERICANS EXCELLENTLY.
THE RELEASE SHOULD NOT BE
EXALTED, IT SHOULD BE EXPECTED.
>> Greg: WHAT A WET BLANKET,
BUT THE DEVELOPMENT PUTTING IN'S
PERSPECTIVE.
TAKING TURNS AFTER SHOCK OF THE
PORN INTEREST, THREE AMERICANS
ARE FREE.
ONCE YOU GET PAST HIS UNSEEDED
LEAD PAST, HIS ENTIRE PAST
REVEALS THAT TALENT.
THEY ELECTED A UNIQUE TOOLKIT
FOR UNIQUE TIMES.
ABLE TO ENGAGE ROGUE REGIMES AND
WHAT THEY UNDERSTAND.
CARROTS AND A REAL STICK, NOT
FANTASY.
WHO KNEW THAT WHAT WE NEEDED
MOST WAS A REALITY TV STAR WHO
ACTUALLY DEALS IN REALITY?
SO WITH THOSE THREE PEOPLE, WHAT
THEY HAVE PREFERRED A SQUEAKY
CLEAN PRESIDENT THREADING ALONE
IN THE OVAL OFFICE AS THEY SAT
IN A FOREIGN JAIL, OR A
BILLIONAIRE TYCOON WHO IS NOT
THE BEST HUSBAND, BUT CAN TALK A
BEAR OFF OF A FISH TRUCK?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
ALL RIGHT, KENNEDY, WELCOME TO
THE SHOW.
YOU LOOK GREAT IN PINK AS ALWAYS
YOU LOOK GREAT IN PINK AS ALWAY
ALWAYS.
WHY IS THIS WORKING?
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO BE WORKING.
BEFORE IT IS OBJECTIVELY GOOD.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR ANYONE
TO ARGUE THAT THIS IS NOT A GOOD
THING.
AND IT IS INTERESTING AND VERY
PREDICTABLE THAT PEOPLE WILL
CERTAINLY TRY.
I THINK THAT THE VISUAL WAS
GREAT OF THE PLANE LANDING, AND
TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
FIRST LADY AND THE SECRETARY OF
STATE THERE TO WELCOME THREE
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES AND RECENT
HISTORY IS ABSOLUTELY
UNIMAGINABLE TO AMERICANS.
NOT THE 1% AND NOT THOSE WHO ARE
COMFORTABLE BUT TO ALL
AMERICANS, WE CANNOT FATHOM WHAT
LIFE IS LIKE BECAUSE VERY FEW
PEOPLE GET OUT TO TELL THE
STORY.
IF YOU REMEMBER AT THE STATE OF
THE UNION, ONE OF THE MOST
MOVING PARTS WAS A MAN WHO WOULD
ESCAPE NORTH KOREA AND TAKE HIS
CLUTCHES IN THAT EMBRACE OF
FREEDOM AND A CONTINUATION OF
THAT NARRATIVE THAT IS INVESTING
IN VERY REAL TERMS.
REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT OR WHO YOU VOTED
FOR, YOU HAVE TO STOP AND
REALIZE THAT THIS IS A GREAT
MOMENT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Greg: JESSE, YOU KNOW THAT
I LIKE IT WAS AT 3:00 A.M.,
TRUMP IS SAYING, I DON'T SLEEP,
HILLARY WOULD BEEN IN BED BY
NOW.
>> Jesse: HE WAS UP FOR THE
3:00 A.M. PHONE CALL, IT IS
PERFECT.
AND GREAT RATINGS AS HE
MENTIONS.
FROM HERE UNTIL THE MOUTH.
I'M SURE THAT THEY WERE REALLY
GOOD.
IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT OLIVE
BRANCH FROM LITTLE ROCKET MAN
PRAYED HE DESERVES A LITTLE BIT
OF CREDIT.
I KNOW THAT IF OBAMA SAID THEY
WERE TREATED EXCELLENT, PEOPLE
WOULD'VE SAID, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING?
BUT I THINK THAT THAT IS JUST
TRUMP'S WAY OF NEGOTIATING.
HE CUTS THEM DOWN WHEN HE NEEDS
TO.
THAT IS GREAT.
IT IS A BIG DISTINCTION OF HOW
OBAMA DEALT WITH THESE THINGS.
REMEMBER OBAMA GOT A CHENEY BACK
BUT HE HAD TO GIVE UP FIVE
TERRORISTS FROM GITMO, WE DID
NOT HAVE TO GIVE UP ANYTHING.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE
FROM THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS GOTTEN BACK
DETAINEES.
WE GOT THEM FROM EGYPT,
AFGHANISTAN, EVEN THE UNGRATEFUL
BASKETBALL PLAYERS FROM UCLA
THAT CAME THROUGH CHINA, THEY
CAME BACK.
HE IS WITH THE GEORGE COSTANZO
METHOD.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
WHENEVER OBAMA DID SOMETHING,
TRUMP DOES THE OPPOSITE IN
NORTH KOREA, SYRIA, IRAN, AND IT
SEEMS TO BE WORKING, JUAN, THE
MEDIA IS NOT ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALL
OF THE FALSE THINGS THEY
PREDICTED WOULD HAPPEN WITH
NORTH KOREA.
THEY SAID WE WOULD ALIENATE THE
AND NOT GET CHINA TO HELP US
OUT.
WE WERE GOING TO GO TO WAR.
AND POMPEO WAS NOT A GOOD
DIPLOMAT.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TURNED
OUT TO BE WRONG.
THE MEDIA IS LIKE A BAD
WEATHERMAN.
EVERY DAY THEY COME OUT AND THEY
SAY IT IS GOING TO RAIN.
AND EVERY DAY IT IS CLEAR SKIES
AND SUNNY.
BUT THEY NEVER APOLOGIZE OR GET
FIRED.
>> Greg: SO, JUAN, FROM A
SCALE OF ONE BEING AWESOME, TEN
BEING SUPER, SUPER, SUPER
AWESOME, WHERE WOULD YOU PUT
THIS?
>> Juan: SUPER, SUPER,
SUPER -- GOSH, I IMAGINE US IN
THAT SITUATION, YOU WANT OUT,
YOU WENT OUT FOR AMERICANS.
IT IS GOOD.
THE PART THAT AMUSES ME FIRST IS
THE BUSINESS ABOUT RATINGS,
CLEARLY IT IS ALL ABOUT THE
APPEARANCES AND HIS POLITICAL
POPULARITY.
IT IS ALL ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS
WILL CELEBRATE.
LET'S PUT DOWN CHUCK SCHUMER FOR
STATING THE OBVIOUS THAT WHAT
YOU REALLY WANT HERE IS KIM JONG
UN WOULD NOT BE HOLDING
AMERICANS AND TREATING THEM SO
BADLY.
AND WE SHOULD NOT BE CALLING HIM
EXCELLENT OR ANYTHING.
JESSE, I WOULD SAY TO YOU THAT
WE DID GIVE SOMETHING TO KIM
JONG UN, WE HAVE GIVEN HIM A
SUMMIT.
PUTTING HIM ON THE LEVEL WITH
US.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HE HAS WANTED THIS ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS THAT HAVE DENIED IT.
HE IS THRILLED THAT HE IS SEEING
A WORLD LEADER EQUAL TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS THE OBAMA
POLICY?
DO NOTHING.
>> Juan: WE DID NOT DO
NOTHING.
WE DO NOT DO NOTHING, BUT WE DID
NOT HAVE ANY SOLUTION.
I THINK THAT THIS IS WHY --
>> Jesse: THE SUMMIT AS A
RESULT OF SANCTIONS AND TOUGH
RHETORIC.
>> Juan: IT IS A RESULT OF
ACTIONS TAKEN IN TERMS OF PRIOR
SANCTIONS, DO, DISTINCTIONS, BUT
I ALSO THINK --
>> Jesse: ALL OF THE ALLIES
ARE VERY HAPPY WITH THE SUMMIT.
THE ALLIANCES ARE STRONG.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU LOOK AT KIM
JONG UN, WHAT HE IS BUILDING
TOWARDS IS THE IDEA OF THE
UNITED STATES EXCEPTING
NORTH KOREA AS A NUCLEAR POWER.
EVERY OTHER AMERICAN PRESIDENT
HAS HAD NO TO THIS.
>> Kimberly: I DO NOT KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE GOING.
THERE IS NOT EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THIS STATEMENT.
>> Greg: ONE TRUMP GETS THE
PRESURPRISE, WILL JUAN SAY, OKAY
PRESURPRISE, WILL JUAN SAY, OKA
OKAY.
>> Kimberly: IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MEDIA REPORTS, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT KIM JONG UN DID
RELUCTANTLY PRAYED HE DID NOT
WANT TO RELEASE THREE AMERICAN
HOSTAGES PAID HE DID SO BECAUSE
OF THE UNIQUE AND NONCONFORMING
DIPLOMATIC POLICY THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENGAGED IN.
THIS IS NOTHING THAT WAS
UNSETTLING TO KIM JONG UN,
SOMETHING THAT HE WAS NOT
FAMILIAR WITH.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED A
DIFFERENT APPROACH.
IT HAS PRODUCED A HISTORICAL
RESULT.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SITUATION, WHY WOULD ANY
AMERICAN NOT SAY THAT THIS IS A
VERY, VERY FAVORABLE AND
AUSPICIOUS RESULT THAT HAPPENS
HERE.
I LOOK AT THE SCREEN AND I SEE
THREE HEALTHY AMERICANS THAT
THOUGHT THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE A
CHANCE.
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO COME HOME
TO THIS COUNTRY.
THANK GOD.
JUXTAPOSED TO THAT FOR OTTO
WARMBIER AND HIS FAMILY, I DO
NOT WANT TO FORGET ABOUT HIM AND
THE SUFFERING THAT HE WENT
THROUGH.
IT IS A BIG MOMENT TO SAY THAT
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE AS A COUNTRY
AND HAPPY IN THIS DIPLOMACY.
>> Kennedy: THINK ABOUT THE
CHILDREN AND THE BABIES THAT
WERE KILLED IN FRONT OF THEIR
PARENTS AND THE NORTH KOREAN
LABOR CANCER.
TO YOUR POINTS, THOSE ON THE
LEFT HAVE BEEN SAYING,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE RHETORIC TO
GET HEATED, THERE WAS SO MUCH
UNPREDICTABILITY THAT PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT TO THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
KNOW WHERE WE WERE GOING IN
TERMS OF NORTH KOREA.
BUT IT SEEMS TO HAVE WORKED OUT,
YOU SAY THAT NO PRESIDENT HAS
GONE TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN, WELL,
NO PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ON THE
PRECIPICE OF A REAL PIECE.
>> Juan: NO, CLINTON AND BUSH
BOTH THOUGHT THEY HAD DEALS,
EITHER WITH HIS FATHER.
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF
THIS BEFORE, KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: IT IS ALL MALARKEY
COMPARED TO.
>> Juan: THEY ALL SAID NO,
BECAUSE THEY KNEW HOW
NORTH KOREA RAN THE PRISONER
CAMPS.
>> Kennedy: THAT IS NOT TRUE,
THEY OFFERED MORE CONCESSIONS
AND ENERGY AND RELAXING
SANCTIONS OF THE AHEAD OF TALKS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
THEY ACTUALLY GAVE TEN SESSIONS
AHEAD OF TIME AND THEN
NORTH KOREA MADE PROMISES THAT
WERE UNVERIFIED AND THEY WERE
NOT EVEN PRESIDENT TO THAT.
THE ONE THING YOU CAN SAY ABOUT
THE PROCESS IS THAT HAS BEEN
REVERSED.
>> Juan: HOUSE THAT REVERSED?
>> Kennedy: BECAUSE KIM JONG
UN GAVE UP SOMETHING BEFORE BOTH
PARTIES.
>> Juan: YOU ARE WRONG, IN
NOVEMBER HE HAD HIS THIRD
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC TEST
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO I DO NOT THINK THAT HE HAS
COMPLETED NOW PREPARATIONS FOR A
COMPLETE NUCLEAR ARSON.
SO YOU STOP ANYTHING, WAIT A
SECOND?
>> Kennedy: WARD IS BETTER?
BOMBING HIM AND THE WEAPONS?
ARE GOING TO THE TABLE --
>> Juan: THAT IS NOT THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE ARE HAVING AT
THIS TABLE.
I AM ALL FOR REUNITING THE
PENINSULA IF WE CAN GET A REGIME
IN NORTH KOREA THAT IS NOT
TORTURING PEOPLE.
>> Kennedy: DEMOCRATS WANT
REGIME CHANGE?
>> Juan: WILL LET ME SPEAK FOR
A MINUTE!
YOU HAVE A GUY WITH NUCLEAR
WEAPONS THAT HE HAS BEEN
TESTING, WE HAVE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS I THOUGHT THEY
HAD A DEAL.
NOW WE HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
HIS RHETORIC AND WE DO NOT KNOW
WHAT KIND OF DEAL.
WHAT HAPPEN WITH THESE THREE
PRISONERS AS MUCH AS WE
APPRECIATE THEM COMING HOME IS
NOT TO BE SEEN AS OH, THIS IS A
RADICAL CHANGE.
>> Jesse: THIS IS WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DO NOT LIKE
WASHINGTON, YOU HAVE ONE AND
CRIME CHUCK WHO WILL NOT GIVE
CREDIT TO.
I REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA KILLED
BIN LADEN, AND THEY GAVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT WAS DUE, TO THE
NAVY SEALs.
BUT THERE IS A SPIRIT OF
BIPARTISANSHIP THAT USED TO
EXIST WHEN GOOD THINGS HAPPEN TO
AMERICA AND AMERICAN CITIZENS
AND PEOPLE WERE MOVING TOWARDS
PEACE.
LET'S JUST REMEMBER THAT THEY
JUST WANTED TO END THE KOREAN
WAR, SINCE 1950, TO SIT BACK AND
NITPICK ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LOOK
SMALL.
AND IT LOOKS PARTISAN.
>> Greg: NOW IT IS SET FOR
SINGAPORE.
>> Kimberly: JULY 12, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE APPROVAL OF
AMERICANS, 77%, SO IF YOU BEG TO
DIFFER, BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
AMERICANS ARE FOR THIS, WE ARE
FOR PEACE AND DIPLOMACY, WE ARE
SITTING DOWN AND HE IS NOT
AFRAID TO BREAK THE MODERN RULES
AND GO TO THIS AND GET ADDED IN
A DIFFERENT ANGLE TO PRODUCE THE
BEST RESULTS.
>> Juan: I DO NOT THINK THAT
THERE IS ANY ARGUMENT ABOUT THAT
THERE IS ANY ARGUMENT ABOUT THA
THAT.
HANG ON A SECOND.
>> Kimberly: IT DOES NOT
MATTER WHETHER POLITICS ARE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE FOR THAT.
>> Juan: I THINK IT SHOULD BE
100%.
I COULD NOT AGREE MORE.
TALKING ABOUT RECONCILIATION
FROM NORTH AND SOUTH.
BUT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT IS IT
THAT WE ARE WILLING TO NEGOTIATE
WITH.
>> Kennedy: CAN I ASK YOU A
VERY QUICK QUESTION?
>> Juan: THIS IS WHAT I SAID
TO JESSE, WHEN YOU HAVE A GREAT
CONCESSION TO THE PRESIDENT OF
NORTH KOREA WHO HAS BEEN SEEN AS
AN INTERNATIONAL --
>> Kimberly: THAT IS NOT A
GREAT CONCESSION.
>> Kennedy: HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO AFFORD THAT?
>> Greg: YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
ELEVATE THE PERSON THAT YOU ARE